[Music]
foreign
let's go ahead and open up the doors as
we are here live on Zoom
live streaming to multiple different
platforms and I love the fact that we
can do one show and be all around the
world at the same time of course it's
not the same time zone it's different
times throughout the world but folks if
you would like to join us with zoom live
here daily withdoc.com is where you want
to go to make sure that you get signed
up for our newsletter and also get
information directly to your email on
how to join us here on the daily with
Doc
if you want to and if you're listening
to here we invite you to join us here
live all you have to do is in that URL
address bar put daily with Doc
zoom.com that is daily with Doc
zoom.com and you are welcome to join us
so I just want to do a come
heartfelt shout out
as we are being broadcasted not on these
different not only on these different
platforms like Spotify YouTube Facebook
um Rumble we're going bridy on truths
all of these different places we are
also syndicated on multiple different
radio stations and I just want to think
Mr Michaels for joining us here each and
every day as he is using this program to
continue to spread the message of Hope
and what you yourself can do as an
empowered individual folks
we have a better
you know grasp of what can and can't
benefit our health
than somebody that's gone through
eight nine years of medical school folks
that had maybe one hour one class that
touched on nutrition
this program is going to be enlightening
you on the importance of nutrition and
with that being said the FDA does
require us to let you know that this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician nor are
the products mentioned
intended to treat diagnose or cure any
diseases but folks when you look at the
research of the man that we have on with
us today and you see the comparative
analysis
taking the data from autopsies of over
000 cases
it just makes sense
my name is Becca dukes and I am honored
to be the hostess of this program
bringing to you the information that
gave me hope
I was told that I had multiple
conditions and then there was nothing
they could do for me because I refused
to go for surgery
um so they pushed me off the pain
management
and then I found this doctor
and he said give me 90 days
so I decided I was going to give him
those 90 days and those 90 days were
over seven years ago over a hundred
pounds ago and no longer
having to deal with the symptoms that
have been
characterized with 13 different
conditions
so folks if you feel like you're just
too young to feel this old
and you're tired of hurting listen up
because I am excited to bring to you the
one the only Dr Joel Wallach who has a
Bachelor of Science in agriculture
Doctorate of veterinary medicine yes he
started
he started with the ones that couldn't
even tell him what was going on folks
and he had to figure it out
and he figured it out so well that he
has saved the White Rhino from
Extinction so if he can save a White
Rhino from Extinction I think he can
really help us humans out too what do
you think
but treating the animals was not enough
so he went on as he was teaching
nutrition at a college level for a
naturopathic College decided to become
also a naturopathic physician and in the
whole process of it all has three post
doctorates in pathology so folks
you're going to want to make sure that
you get back with the person that shared
this program with you
and tell them thank you
this is a resource for an amazing
Community amazing community of people
some of them are health coaches some of
them are certified holistic health
coaches some are just those who have a
passion to see people thrive
so get back with that person that shared
this program with you tell them thank
you and say hey I want more information
can you help me out
if there's nobody to think you are
welcome to join us and go to daily
withdoc.com as I do have a group of
people who are here for those who have
never spoken to anybody about youngevity
have never tried the products and are
ready to make a change so if you're one
of those people you can call our team at
855-949-3377 or go to our website daily
withdoc.com we do have a contact option
where you can click contact and it'll
send us an email let us know what you
would like to work on if you have goals
that you would like to reach then reach
out to us and let us see what we can do
to to assist you in making those goals
it all has to do with you and your
actions
okay the first action
is to say hey I got something going on
I need some help
admitting that you have a goal that you
yourself cannot reach on your own
because we are here to help people
thrive folks not just barely survive
so with that being said I started this
earlier
but I gotta make all of those things all
those little statements
um because we are an amazing Community I
don't want to bypass anybody in our
community I just spent the weekend with
almost 50 of them uh and just had an
incredible time loving and hugging and
learning with a group of health coaches
so folks without further Ado it is my
great honor and privilege to bring to
you Dr Joel Wallach hello Dr Wallach I
know you missed me yes so we miss you
you're going for four or five days and
uh we couldn't wait till you get back
well it has been
a day without Rebecca's like a day
without Sunshine oh you're so sweet Dr
Wallach well what do you have for us
today
well I think one of the things that
people have to appreciate is that the
human body is very complex
and it requires a minimum of 90
essential nutrients just to sort of
maintain itself and function just to
walk just to breathe uh okay to eat and
digest food and that sort of stuff
and then
this requires 90 essential nutrients 16
minerals 16 vitamins chromium so Three
fatty acids
and then with all these organs you know
you have a heart you have lungs you have
liver you have digestive system stomach
and intestines and you have pancreas and
and so on and then you have muscles and
bones and ligaments and tendons and
connective tissue and skin and brains
and spinal cords and eyes and all the
and they all require not only the 90
essential nutrients but further
functions special nutrients in addition
to the 90 they call them secret sauces
okay
and so it's one of those things where
um the old days people unknowingly were
getting not totally because nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform blank
around the crust of the earth they turn
in veins like gold and silver
but when people lived in certain places
they were getting all 90 essential
nutrients well where did they get their
60 minerals from wood ashes and coal
ashes when they use wood and coal for
fuel for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years unknowingly they were
putting the wood ashes and coal ashes
and their food is a spice you're also
putting it in their Gardens and they
knew that when they put wood ashes and
coal ashes into the gardens they got a
bigger yield bigger Tomatoes more
tomatoes that kind of thing
and bigger onions more onions and they
knew that but they did not know that the
plants were sucking up the minerals were
in those ashes and when you ate the
vegetables grow in the garden they were
fertilized with the ashes you were
getting Minerals Well three o'clock in
the afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
on Pearl Street in New York City and the
bluff overlooking the construction of
Brooklyn Bridge Thomas says and pulled
the switch
for the 18 years by 1900 the turn of the
20th century we were coming down with 50
new diseases that people never seen
before
that's because we no longer had access
to these minerals through the wood ash
and Coalition so we were using
electricity there was no more ashes that
were produced when you switched to
electricity
and this was a big turn this was a big
term going from thousands and thousands
and thousands of years of getting our
nutritional minerals from wood ashes and
coal Ashes to go into electricity and
suddenly now we didn't have these
nutrients anymore so the only way you
can guarantee you're going to get them
is to supplement and we learned this in
the animal industry we don't have health
insurance for animals
veterinarian doesn't have to come out to
the farm every day to treat the animals
like they do people okay and so why is
that well because we learned
from economics and from science and
that's I learned it in the inventory
school as well as agricultural school
about soils and and plants and animal
diseases
these are caused by
deficiencies of vitamins minerals
and Doctors medical doctors want to give
you fast relief they'll give you
painkillers oh I just love my doctor had
his pain for years he gave me this new
pain reliever man in 30 seconds that
pain was gone I just love them but he
didn't deal with what was causing the
pain so the disease kept getting worse
and worse worse you had to use more and
more of the of the painkiller and then
you had to get another painkiller
another painkiller and then you die
because doctors are taught to relieve
symptoms
they rarely get to the basic root cause
of the problem okay and so this is this
is what we teach people if you want to
have Healthy Families you want to add 25
to 50 health of the Earth's your life
your family's life this is not difficult
this is not difficult okay we have over
a hundred years 123 years okay of
learning how to deal with this
nutritionally in animals and actually
with animals it goes back even farther
okay they learn there were certain
things they would give salt blocks to
animals
okay and the animals will stand there
and lick that salt block all the time
and people started taking salt for
themselves okay well doctors say salt is
bad no sodium chloride are two of the
nutrients you require for life and if
you stop salting your food you're in
trouble you're going to get problems
okay because your cells won't be healthy
you won't be able to deal with
um your blood pressure your your
um uh kidneys will be unhappy you don't
want that every cell in your body
requires sodium chloride which is salt
in the old days when you did something
good everybody said oh you're the salt
of the earth because they knew if you
had goiter and they gave you sea salt
your gutter would go away now they
didn't know what it was in the sea salt
because the garden will go away but they
learned just from accidental observation
that if you gave somebody sea salt that
had a glider within weeks or glider
would go away
now doctors want to use surgery
okay and so you have to say Okay I'm
going to participate here and then when
I started out when it was first a
veterinarian and then became a naturally
doctor I would tell my patients they
said well you're in an area I'm going to
treat you like a dog but you're going to
get better
and you'll be blessed if you allow your
doctor to treat you like a dog because
you will get better whereas if you're
going to be treated like a human being
oh you're in trouble okay no one you'll
be on 8 10 12 15 20 different drugs and
they're all designed to relieve symptoms
not to prevent or cure disease
so with that said I'll turn it back to
you
well Dr Wallach that is absolutely spot
on
they are trained and fabulous when it
comes to like emergency medicine and if
there's something broken or something
that has to be stitched back together or
but they don't look at the preventative
of what it takes or the underlying cause
rather
of why there's dysfunction within the
body
so as you were going through your
autopsies with the different animals and
finding causes of death in people and
humans and people
and you were doing that comparative
pathology which tell us a little bit
about what comparative pathology is
well comparative pathologies when you
look at the same disease and animals and
people and that's why they started
laboratory animals laboratory wraps and
guinea pigs and rabbits and monkeys and
that sort of stuff so you could do
experiments with drugs on animals so
they knew or to give people for pain
relief again relieving symptoms okay
but
um
the
the big one was I did 20 000 autopsies
on a 21 million dollar Grant from the
National Institutes of Health
it was based on my first
written paper okay and it was published
in 1965 in Benadryl journals of
veterinary medicine in the United States
I did autopsies on 50 dead Lambs
this farmer had 500 Lambs they were six
months old they're gonna after Christmas
they were going to share them after New
Year's they're going to take them to be
slaughtered and make lamb chops okay
well
about a week before Christmas all the
professors were gone so I'm working my
way through veterinary school getting
paid so I can pay the tuition inventory
School in the Pathology Department and
this farmer brings me 50 deadlines and
oh my gosh what happened he tells me
well yesterday I had 500 healthy lambs
and this morning they're all dead what
they were perfectly healthy yesterday no
symptoms no disease nothing they were
eating and running around playing like a
six-month-old lamb wood this morning
they were all dead
well when I looked at these Lambs they
all had goiter their blood was black not
dark red but black so I said do you have
other farms around you yeah what animals
they have he's none they all raised like
hay and corn and oh what fertilizer they
use he said well they use a lot of
nitrate fertilizers okay where did your
Lambs get their drinking water we have a
pot I said I need some water so he calls
his employee in two hours they bring me
two five gallon buckets worth of water
and we analyzed it sure enough it was
just loaded with nitrate fertilizer when
nitrates actually cause
the thyroid to enlarge and dysfunction
in this process and when the temperature
dropped that night that's what happened
the temperature went from an average of
50 for the past month every day 50 50 50
50. dropped to 16 and they couldn't
maintain their body temperature and they
all died of hypothermia
okay now that was my first
scientific publication okay this college
in this Veterinary General General very
medicine
um and
um I was in Africa as you point out
working on the White Rhino conservation
project and doing autopsies on all the
animals in the area to different species
of animals is where the Rhino we're
living and trying to figure out why they
weren't making it and so forth and we
figured it all out and back then there
was only like 350 left last
uh December we have 21 000 now so I'm
very very proud of that okay and we can
do the same thing with humans
because we know what causes these
diseases we know what you have to do to
prevent them and how to reverse them and
so people have to make choices do you
want your family to add 25 to 50 Health
viewers your life their lives okay are
you just prepared to let them go see the
doctor you know once a week or twice a
week or three times a week get all these
prescriptions and then work on their
symptoms 24 hours a day and they're
miserable and everybody in the family is
miserable because nobody's happy
nobody's healthy but they're getting
their Medicaid and it's being paid for
it by insurance
yeah it's nice to have you know somebody
else pay for it but folks
why have it as a reason to have to have
somebody pay for something so that you
can just take a pill
Dr Wallach you were talking about the
nitrates
and that is something that has been used
in the the curing and processing of
meats and lunch meats and all of these
different things that are convenient
that's correct and your study was in the
early
1960s is that correct and that's correct
says the the Sheep all died in 1963 the
published it was published in 65.
okay so that was in 1965 and then I know
all through my childhood
we ate lunch meats
I had some thyroid issues and then I
looked at people around me and uh and
the questions that are coming in
hypothyroidism hyperthyroidism
Hashimoto's thyroidism all of these
different things that you in 1965
published a paper that linked nitrates
to goiter which is a thyroid issue
and I am happy I am happy to see that
within the last 10 years they've started
doing no nitrates no added nitrates I
should say
into the lunch meats and such so they've
maybe figured it out and maybe they saw
your paper
it's our job to make sure that everybody
gets this information Dr Wallach not
just the few
because it's very possible that it's a
simple solution
to what has created huge havoc in
somebody's life well that's why we have
such a high regard for you and your team
because you're getting this information
out there to so many different people
around the world and we're very very
excited about that
and
um we're picking up some more countries
here pretty quick
um I'll be dealing with that this
afternoon and so because it heard what
good things that we're doing and says
well we need your help okay for 38
countries okay we have an organization
38 countries which are not in your
youngevity program right now but we want
to get in there okay and so I'm very
very excited about this because we're
going to help millions of more people
with this information and so get ready
to be busy Becca
well Dr Wallach it we're we're already
busy
you're gonna have to find a couple more
people like me to help take some of
these pieces because I am just one
person and in addition to you know
reaching those countries Dr warlick
we've got new radio programs and
syndications coming on as well so folks
if you are part of an organization or a
business where you do have access to be
able to help choose programming and you
would like to get this information out
make sure that you contact us we have on
our team somebody that is
then very
um
influential and has been a huge resource
in getting you out on the broadcast
networks Dr Wallach and we're going to
pick that back up with it being more
than just radio with all the different
podcasters and the video casters and the
influencers that are out there that
people are following on the different
things like Instagram and Twitter and
all of these things there's too many to
mention
but folks if you're in a position where
you would like to get this information
shared with your audience please make
sure that you go to daily with doc.com
use that contact option and send us an
email I will make sure that we get and I
do make sure that we go through all of
the emails and get them addressed and uh
responded to as quickly as possible
and I had mentioned Dr Wallach you know
we have somebody on our team that's been
very instrumental in getting you on the
radio and she has her hand up right now
um and has some questions that are being
passed out on the different platforms so
folks you know as I mentioned if you've
got a program
that you want to get Dr Wallach on we
have an amazing person that has Decades
of experience making that happen so
Phyllis
what questions do you have for Dr wallig
today oh Becca you are you're so kind
and I do give Andy full credit for going
after the radio stations you know yes
God forbid I could never have done that
but um we certainly had a whole support
team going so that was wonderful
um there are a couple of interesting
questions on YouTube Doc you're talking
about the sheep that died because their
thyroids were exposed to the
contaminated water and then the
temperature dropped down and it was very
cold we have Paulina on YouTube is
asking and and this is interesting to me
living in 115 degree heat is excessive
heat harmful to our thyroid glands
yes excessive heat and not enough heat
you know when you're cold
you're gonna die okay from
um
from the temperature that's too low when
it's too hot you're going to die from
temperature this is too high and 98.6 is
where we're supposed to be okay and
120 I mean you see this in in the
newspapers every day now it's on the TV
it's on the radio that these people are
all dying from heat in their car their
kids are dying from here they just run
into the grocery store for five minutes
to get some of your grocery store they
leave their kids in the car seat in the
car they come back the kids fried okay
and so it's one of those things where
um temperature is one of the biggest
killers
okay too much heat is one of the biggest
killers in America
wow that is is fascinating and and uh I
certainly am not staying outside any
longer than I need to in this kind of
record heat and we had another question
off of YouTube from moshta who uh and of
course you often talk about putting
plant derived minerals on the skin to
help them get absorbed and he was
wondering
um to improve absorption is there
something else some other liquid or item
that we have in youngevity to put on the
skin to help absorption or is there
perhaps another route that people can
increase their level of absorption
yes what we have our ultimate enzymes I
take three of those twice a day okay and
sometimes it'll take three three times
it depending on how big a lunch I have
and this is to maximize absorption of
the nutrients
minerals vitamins Amino so fatty acids
but I'll tell you a quick story Pastor
Mike Freeman up in Baltimore Maryland
this is about 10 years ago
Pastor Freeman was in a coma for six
weeks and the doctors called his family
and said you know
um
Pastor only has minutes to live he may
live an hour or so but five minutes or
something so you better get here and say
your goodbyes he's unconscious he may or
may not be able to hear you but at least
you'll feel like you've said your
goodbyes to let you know that he's he's
not long for this world
and so his wife and one of our great
Distributors up there in Baltimore
Maryland Linda Tyler
um called me after visiting him and said
Doc is there anything we can do for
Pastor Mike I mean he's totally out of
it just giving him minutes to live I
said well does he have a G2 he can put
some stuff down the G-tube into the
stomach no does he have an idea even put
stuff in his IV no it's okay just take a
bottle of our liquid plant minerals I
want you to take a half a cup
um three times a day okay on
um his sternum
his upper belly and his lower belly and
also on his back between his shoulder
blazes upper back lower back
three times a day okay
and
call me you know every once while let me
know if anything's happening
well two and a half days later
Miss Linda calls me said oh my gosh
oh my gosh Pastor Mike gets up this
morning
he gets up this morning he shaves he
goes back to the church he goes to his
TV studio His Radio studio and he spends
12 hours telling the world about his
experience with these minerals on his
skin to correct things that doctors
couldn't fix okay
and
thank God he recorded it
and we've made a tool out of it that
everybody can hear him telling the story
okay
it's called Praise the Lord and pastor
90. crazy learning past if ever in the
military you know praise the Lord and
pass the ammunition he went God on your
side was in her shooting War we also
want ammunition Bill to shoot back at
the people shooting at you the same way
here with your illness God is on your
side you want God to give everything
that is needed to make you healthy but
also you want to
um use God's tools okay to defend
yourself and here again
he's telling the story on this DVD this
is a DVD set okay now praise the Lord
and Pastor 90 everybody needs at least
one of those for the family to listen to
and watch oh my gosh and we continue to
tell the story and it really works for
you and little bitty kids you know who
are three months old two weeks old that
aren't doing well
and uh just won't eat and that kind of
stuff and the doctor just Shrugged their
shoulder to say well this one might not
make it and so they didn't rub these
plant middles in their little bellies
and their backs and everything and so
many of them the next day they're just
totally different people because it's
almost like intravenously absorb it
through their skin okay so every family
needs that praise the Lord and Pastor 90
deity
I get to them because people are going
to keep them show them to their friends
so if they want to get a couple of them
so you have one to share with your
family
go ahead no no go ahead you you make
such a good point that these are
situations where they could not consume
the minerals very well yet they were
very effective imagine how effective
taking them internally as we do drinking
the minerals how extremely effective
that is that's correct I I'm also
wondering if
um their diet is going to affect their
degree of absorption and we talk about
the bad foods interfering with
absorption so that's obviously a big
piece of the puzzle isn't it well yes of
course one of the one of the worst
things that we do is um we eat bread
it goes way back thousands of years okay
and of course thousands of years ago the
average lifespan was 37.
and God said in man's ears shall be 120
but the average lifespan of people in
Europe was 37.
why is that because they were eating
bread made from wheat bread around oats
gluten they could not absorb nutrition
because their intestines are dead
okay then in Asia they eat a buckwheat
in certain places in Europe to eat
buckwheat there's no gluten in it but
they do have phagocyines and they're
fago Pyrenees which are 10 times worse
than gluten your intestines should look
like a shag rug with all those little
Villi okay but when you're eating gluten
and Faygo Pyrenees from buckwheat those
will I go and suddenly now you have a
smooth instead of looking like a shag
rug your intestines look like a plastic
tube you've lost 90 of your absorptive
surface because I just I don't know I'm
taking all these vitamins and minerals
it's not working for me
what do you have for breakfast every
morning well I have Wheaties I have
Cheerios I have oatmeal I have buckwheat
pancakes well that's why you're killing
yourself with all that gluten and fago
Pyrenees stop it and within two weeks
time they start seeing benefit within
four weeks time
they're 50 better when within 90 days
are totally reverse of all their health
problems
because now they're absorbing the
nutrition by getting rid of the bad
stuff got it thank you so much and hold
the Wheaties yeah hold the Wheaties yeah
hold the Cheerios hold the buckwheats
and hold
um
all the oatmeal
okay and and even even the pancakes you
know made from
um
um uh oats and that sort of stuff
um even
um things like pizza
we have pizza where the crust is made
from what
cauliflower cauliflower
or truly gluten-free flowers Dr Wallace
not just cauliflower okay well yeah
gluten-free flours it could be rice and
that sort of stuff Millet and so on but
you cannot have wheat in any form you
cannot have wheat butter or oats in any
Farm especially you don't even say the
word out loud okay
well and it's and it's the protein
within them that our bodies can't Digest
yeah it's well it's the
which I say you can't absorb even if you
are digesting yes or no it doesn't
matter because if your intestines are
dead you can't absorb anything
that's true true very true
all right Dr Wallach let's go right over
to AJ who has a question and AJ go ahead
unmute yourself
hello doc how are you today okay sir how
can we help you uh a woman named Donna
is mentioning that that her
um iron levels are high
she's not sleeping and dealing with high
stress and she mentioned a personal
matter also she'd like to be off of
hormone replacement she's on has a
hormone replacement patch but she's
still dealing with her night sweats and
mood swings she's five foot tall
117 pounds and she's 69 years old and
she says thank you very much for all
that you do
okay
so 117 pounds right yes sir okay well
she's getting rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils no gluten so wheat nobody Ryan oats
no sugar no carbon or drinks even the
diet drinks need to go and permanent
water we had a very famous person a
couple of weeks ago that he said I'm
doing everything right I pay people to
make sure I'm doing everything right and
I'm still having the problems and then
we found out after questioning him he
was drinking a juice every morning it
was a juice in carbonated water and he
couldn't absorb because of neutralizing
the stomach acid you need the stomach
acid to be able to digest and absorb
nutrients and if you're drinking
carbonation it neutralizes your stomach
acid so you cannot digest or absorb
okay so that's a big thing then at 117
pounds I wanted to have one healthy
brand heart per month the half of those
are only twice a day I wanted to have
one bottle of our MSM a month so you
take three of breakfast at dinner time
that's going to support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
the vertebrae bone rates bone itself I
wanted to have
are let's see here I do want her to have
our seraphim to go ahead and take two of
those twice a day I'd go ahead and get
two bottles a month of the seraphim so
if Finance are not a problem to take
three twice a day is there a film that's
going to help her with her
um hormone issues and then see we have
sleepies she could take our sleepies you
know like 15 minutes for bedtime all
right and
um then uh let's see here
uh I think oh she had high iron levels
that means she's not converting iron
into hemoglobin and so that's where this
for the
um MSM comes in because it helps your
bone marrow make red blood cells and use
that iron to make more ribose so instead
of letting the iron just float around
okay and so at MSM she could take um two
miles a month so you could take three
three times a day and that'll help her
deal with the iron issue okay
and so um let's you know let's start
there and then
um over time uh you know you guys can
contact us and we'll walk her through
the things that she still needs a little
help with but she's going to see
remarkable results with that program
well you're very kind thank you you're
fantastic
AJ's been a fantastic part of this crew
Dr Wallach that is for sure helping us
go bigger farther faster uh with the
same effort in in many cases so the
enormous people skills you know he does
I guess I have some pretty good from his
reflection he comes from
yes from that and I get to spend
um several hours with him yesterday and
just how he interacted with people and
he just he's just a joy to be around so
that fits right into our team
that's for sure so thank you so much AJ
for all that you do and uh Dr Wallach I
have a question coming out from Virgil
and just a reminder folks that if we ask
your question or you have a question and
Dr while it gives you a program and
recommendations
using the products that he was very
instrumental in helping and formulating
from a company that he was the founder
of make sure that you get back with the
person that shared this program with you
they cared enough to share this program
with you so care enough about and have
respect enough for them to give them the
opportunity to help you find that better
journey to Wellness because we're in the
business of helping people with Wellness
not maintaining sickness folks it's not
a Band-Aid or a bandage that you put
over and mask the symptoms we're working
on the
root cause and healing
but you can say that I can't there's see
there's things that you can say Doc
because you know you've done all the
research and you have those that
alphabet soup that's 10 miles long
that uh those of us you know it doesn't
make any sense even though we've felt it
ourselves Dr Wallach
that there is censorship like that so we
want to make sure that we
are somewhat
um
abiding by the law so that we can
continue to do what we are doing that's
correct abide by the laws
yeah but not be afraid to speak or truth
so Dr Wallach Virgil is a 52 year old
truck driver and he almost failed his
DOT physical now for those of you who do
not know Department of Transportation
physical makes or breaks your career if
you are an over the road driver
especially driving those big trucks
he says my blood pressure was too high
and I need to get it down without
traditional doctors and drugs also being
52 I'm curious what vitamins should I be
taking I have arthritis in my hands but
not crippling yet I'm so I'm able to
continue my everyday activities so Dr
Wallach for somebody who has elevated
blood pressure and arthritis at 52 years
old and 200 pounds let's say he's six
foot tall I didn't get that information
from him what would you recommend for
him he's asking for the vitamins to help
himself so what would you recommend
okay well he needs more than vitamins
he's vitamins and minerals and people I
think people people don't have that
separation that they are not the same
say oh I take my vitamins
well minerals are not a vitamin and
there's over what 600 different
conditions
for health conditions that have been
linked to mineral deficiencies so folks
taking vitamins is not enough Doc's
going to tell you what okay so at um 200
pounds I want Virgil get rid of all the
bad stuff no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat and
Barbara Ryan oats no buckwheat uh
there's no gluten in buckwheat but it
has Sago Pyrenees which are 10 times
worse no sugar no carbonator drinks even
the diet drinks got to go and carbonated
water has to go because they neutralize
stomach acid and 200 pounds for them to
have two healthy branded heart packs per
month two healthy Brandon hard passion
about the photos everything twice a day
and then I want him to have uh let's see
here
um two bottles a month of the MSM so you
take three of breakfast three laundry
dinner time and they're going to support
and promote major pair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between a vertebrae bone makes bone cell
for the for the joints and arthritis and
that kind of stuff
and then for the blood pressure I'm
going to have two bottles a month of our
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three breakfast straight lunch through
dinner time and they're going to support
and promote healthy blood pressure and
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries in the brain the heart the
kidneys and so forth and so let's start
there and if he has pain in his joints
we do have the CM cream he can apply the
same cream to the joints he'll get about
two to four hours of pain relief okay
and um
the the system works I mean I've been
dealing with pro basketball players you
know Theo Ratliff is a great story there
um his story of course is in in the um
clip charts coming out here pretty soon
great story and um he it was so very
successful uh I think he's also in that
CD a dead athletes don't lie I think
that he's in that one also and he came
back uh his career is over he had a
fracture and a shooting arm wrist he had
bone to bone arthritis uh in his knees
and his hips and the doctors want to
give him knee surgery and hip surgery
and his career was gonna be over and so
to make a long story short I rebuilt him
okay and we had to come up with the
healthy Bone and Joint pack we didn't
have one okay so we just had a multiple
so he came up with a healthy Bone and
Joint pack which was our multiple and we
added the glucogel to it okay which is a
collagen and so that made it the healthy
bone joint fact okay and then we came up
with a rebound for theorealive or sports
drink with 100 nutrients and 75 minerals
and 20
um five vitamins citizens isn't a
trucker he can he can use our rebound
sport shrink as well
and you want to use if you're going to
use the carbonated ones do pop the tops
on them tonight before you're going to
drink them put them in the refrigerator
then drink them the next day because
carbonation will neutralize stomach acid
okay we do have the sticks okay and on
the road these seeds work very well
there's one dose of rebound 75 minerals
and 25 vitamins amino acids Red Bull
only has one mineral
yeah there's falling short Doc well well
yeah so short okay uh you need you need
60. we're giving you 75
and Red Bull only has one magnesium okay
so there's a problem there they have
they have lots of caffeine lots of sugar
and that's what they're giving you the
energy with is the caffeine and the
sugar we have a little bit of caffeine
to share but it's like 25 percent of
what you're gonna get in the Red Bull
because we're giving you all these
nutrients and that's what's making
everything work so well and it's for so
long because it's maintaining the
function of all your tissues and so
forth including the muscles and hearts
and blood vessels and kidneys and liver
and so on
so I I think uh Virgil is going to be
happy with the results here and um do
call us on a regular basis we'll walk
you through this so you're gonna have a
great story
all right thank you Virgil for
submitting that through email I do have
one of our coaches on it with the
recommendation that Dr Wallach shared
today and that will be coming back to
you in an email
Dr Wallach the next question that we
have with us today here live in Zoom is
coming from JT
JT's question is in regards to a 65 year
old woman five foot eight inches 145
pounds with stage 4 liver cirrhosis
anemia
she has started on the brain and heart
pack MSM selenium EFA EFA plus ultimate
enzymes and she started that on Friday
she says she's been feeling abnormally
tired and slept 20 hours
um feeling foggy and the brain and
Bloated in the belly
wondering what might be causing this and
is this normal
have glycemia okay because if she was
deficient in those nutrients since she
um had high blood sugar and you're
taking these nutrients send it out it'll
knock your blood sugar down and put you
to sleep
okay so this is not uncommon okay
um but that resolves itself once you get
everything normalized and so this guy
here
this woman yeah this woman
um 145 pounds uh we want her to have uh
get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed means no oils no
glutens no wheat in America
um now let's see here no buckwheat
because of the fago Pyrenees no sugar no
uh let's see here no carbonated drinks
even the the diet one's got to go and
also the carbon
um just carbonated water has to go
and then at 145 pounds I wanted to have
two healthy brain and heart pasture
month two healthy brain and heart
passionate about the photos everything
twice a day and because she has a liver
issues additionally uh we want her to
have
um let's see here I would go with the uh
I-26 go with the I-26 take we have
chewables we have powder we have
capsules and pills and the liver is very
very important uh and of course deliver
can help you prevent Parkinson's disease
I'm doing all this research and you know
in animals that have a chronic you know
wasting
disease and that sort of stuff and
they don't have any cholesterol okay and
they're just tired all the time and
losing weight and functionalism and so
forth well that's because they don't
have any cholesterol so I try to find
out where where are these deer getting
their cholesterol from were these people
getting their cholesterol from well I
can't have cholesterol my doctor said no
cholesterol so I don't need eggs I don't
eat meat I just eat a lot of grain oh
wheat butter and oats there you go
okay and so that's why you're having
problems so then uh let's see here we
also want the our Sports rank rebound
okay
and
um the I'd go with the ultimate daily
classic tablets I take three of those
twice a day two miles a month that's
going to help with blood pressure and
blood flow and also the MSM will help
with the formation of white blood cells
and red blood cells and platelets and
bone marrow and so forth and this is
what's going to be needed to get all
this stuff in line okay but liver
cirrhosis
is more than just liver cirrhosis
because it's it the liver makes 40
different products that you cannot get
from your food the liver makes 40
different things that your body needs so
you need to be pumping all the nutrition
to that liver to make sure it's doing
everything it needs to because if you
don't get what you need
because your liver can't make it you're
going to get
Alzheimer's disease you're going to get
Parkinson's disease you're going to get
Ms disease and it's all because well my
as my liver all these things are the
brain yeah but the brain is 25 to 50
percent uh uh uh cholesterol and your
liver makes most makes 80 of the
cholesterol you require
they'll deliver
makes nutrients that support
overall function that's correct live
if the liver is like full of toxins
then it's the ability to be able to do
those functions aren't going to be as
successful
or not at all
so a new product Dr Wallach that um
you're not quite as familiar with it's
called our ultimate daily digest and
that are there's individual pouches it
has four different uh capsules in it
that all support digestion and liver
function so has a little extra something
in there that helps with the liver and
I've had some people have amazing
results adding that to their protocol
that you have given to them Dr Wallach
okay well read the label today
I will put it in front of you too well
thank you absolutely
Dr Wallach I have one more question here
before we have to go before time is up
with you and Jim is wanting to thank us
every month or thank us for our email
for our newsletter and he wants to know
what your recommendations are Dr Wallach
for tinnitus or ringing in the ears he
says I'm 68 years old in very good
health
including my hearing but I've had this
very annoying ringing in my ears for the
last few years
so Dr Wallach per 100 pounds because
this is not just a man thing it's a
woman issue also so let's just go buy a
hundred pounds what would be your
recommendation to allow somebody to give
their body what they need for
eliminating or reducing this ringing in
the ears
well and Dr Wallach is holding up for
those of you who are not watching the
video and are on one of our audio
broadcasts he's holding up the book it's
all in your head
so tell us about it's all in your head
doc well the book and the series the
book and CD set goes into obviously
approaches a skull and the 37 different
diseases you can get when you obviously
approach to the skull and one of the
more common ones is tinnitus or tinnitus
depending what part of the country
you're from okay and uh that's the
auditory branch of the atrial nerve
being squeezed there's a whole chapter
on base cranial nerve there's a whole
chapter on each of the 12 pairs of
cranial nerves okay and so there's a lot
of questions I'd like to ask this person
but
is one of those things where they need
per 100 pounds of body weight one
healthy brain and hard pack per month
half of those everything twice a day MSM
uh per 100 pounds of body weight one
bottle a month take three twice a day
per 100 pounds of body weight that's
going to rebuild the cartilage and
ligaments and tendons connective tissue
including bone marrow including the
skull okay and then collagen peptides
let's go without the morning drinks go
to the evening drink
and then
um we need them to have the I-26 the
I-26
um I like the chewables I take two of
the chewables three times a day we do
have the capsules we have the powder and
they help you rebuild the myelin the
white matter the brain is spinal cord
okay including the atrial nerve all
right
and let's see here they also need the
um uh synaptive two miles a month I can
take two or three of those twice a day
for so the brain cells can talk to each
other
e2038 saw scrambled or soft poached for
breakfast and dinner every day
and they will give you what you need for
your brain to work properly so all these
sort of things that people are
complaining about won't happen at all
but if they're happening they reverse
very quickly but when you read that book
I get so many people call me say oh my
gosh my doctor never told me about this
where they don't get taught these things
in medical school and that's why uh Dr
Milan and Beck and myself we wrote the
book and the CD set okay and so we have
the book and the CD set it's on your
head covers 37 different diseases your
doctor is going to refer you to as
classmates
okay or a specialist you have ring in
your ears and the doctor wants to send
you to his classmate who's an ear nose
and throat doctor so you can have
hearing aids okay well that's not the
issue okay the issue is you're not
getting the what you need to have your
atrial nerve work because the skull is
squeezing it
so there you go well then they've got
quite the network going on Dr Wallach
because you've got your primary care
they send you to a specialist that
specialist sends you to another
specialist
that then sends you to sends your
information to a lab so you know when
people look at network marketing I tell
you what folks doctors have probably one
of the most expensive network marketing
platforms there is and what are they
doing they're masking the symptoms
they're not addressing underlying and
causes
so Dr Wallach something and I know you
have to go something that you have done
many times is refer to the Good Foods
bad foods list folks thank you Dr Wally
yeah I gotta run we'll talk to you later
um but folks you can find the good foods
bad foods list down daily with doc.com
there we have that whole list so that
you can print it out or save it do
screenshots whatever is needed so that
you have it at your fingertips as you
are going shopping and make sure that
you're focused on that good side
okay if there's things on the bad side
they just don't go on the shopping cart
there's lots of things on the good side
that even covers the four food groups
okay
for those of you who want to have a
balanced meal balanced plate you still
get your Ford food groups but you are
eliminating those foods that are causing
toxicity within the body that have been
found to
be part of the cause
of for health conditions
so if I could get my co-host up with me
that would be greatly appreciated
because I could not do this program
without them
we've got Ruth Ellen Sanchez who is my
executive production manager I just
appreciate her and and all of her
organization and making sure everything
is the way it's supposed to be and then
we have her assistant AJ
who is not only helping make sure
everything where it's supposed to be but
it's making it go bigger faster farther
stronger all around the world so thank
you so much AJ for all that you do and
bringing in your expertise and talents
into the team we have sherry who has
some amazing talents also I mean people
skills people if you've got people
skills and you want to work with people
and and and help them identifying
what might be something that's holding
them back and then having these
solutions to help them break through
our whole team is made up of health
coaches and Sherry is just one of those
fantastic health coaches that's coming
with multiple
multiple uh degrees or certificates
there you can see them right behind her
and making sure that she has that
training that qualifies her so we don't
all have
you know that wall behind us that we can
do that but I love the fact that you've
done that Sherry and we also have
Phyllis which I shared a little bit
about Phyllis earlier and all of the
things that she and her husband Andy who
I just love and adore have done over the
decades in getting this message out to
the masses and I just love the fact that
you know even though Andy's at
retirement age Phyllis is not but they
continue to push through and make sure
that this information is getting shared
where they are able and we have the
amazing Marilyn who is bringing more of
her skills also to the table as she is
amazing at doing the dictation of what
Dr Wallach is recommending and putting
it in the zoom
chat which is one of the benefits of
being here live with us Monday through
Friday from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time
so we invite you to go to daily
withdoc.com so that you can join us
during that time
and ask your questions or just listen be
part of this Crusade
that is making a stronger world
folks so majority of us are in the
United States but we are not limited to
the United States as we are going all
the way down into South Africa because
folks
a human is a human is a human is so if
one human needs vitamins and minerals
and essential fatty acids all of them do
so I love the fact that Albert has
acknowledged that too and He is wanting
to help his community and help us also
reach around the world so thank you so
much Albert as he um has an incredible
passion and love for people and also
experiencing Distributing stuff when it
comes to some very important
um Commodities around the world so thank
you so much Albert for joining our team
and folks my name is Becca Dukes
I love the fact that I can use my
experience not just my experience from
from work and training and citizenship
leadership all of these different things
raising animals having to to do it all
and to realize that
and I came to realization that I was
looking at the labels
of the animal foods that I was feeding
my livestock more than I was for my own
self
and for those of you who have pets you
might be able to relate to that you take
a lot of time and Care into making sure
that that pet gets the best
well it's time to consider that without
you there would be nobody to take care
of that pet or those children or those
loved ones so it's time to make sure
that you are taking care of yourself and
investing not only the time that you
took to listen to this program
but taking those steps and investing in
your own health with formulations that
are proven day and day
over and over again
to be beneficial within the body
again my name is Becca dukes and I
invite you to go to daily withdoc.com
there you will find a replays of our
programming you will also find a store
that lists all of the products that Dr
Wallach has mentioned today you'll find
the good foods bad foods list plus
you'll find more supporting documents
and also audios and videos from
pharmacists Ben Fuchs on the importance
of nutrition and how it relates to
health
get back with the person that you
heard about this program from
if you want to get started on a program
get back with them tell them thank you
for sharing this program with you and
ask them if they have a way to help you
get what Dr Wallach has recommended
if there is nobody to think and you
would like to get connected with a host
a co-host not a coach
got to get the right c word in there and
you'd like to get connected with a coach
feel free to give us a call at
855-949-3377 I do have a team that are
scheduled throughout the week throughout
the hours of the day there to assist you
if by chance you get the voicemail
please leave a message we do get back to
those leave messages and we also have
email
you can use the contact option in the
menu at Daily withdoc.com and reach us
through email as well so until next time
bye for now
recording stopped
[Music]
foreign